[Music]
on this monday night
forced to pivot during the pandemic
doctors become icu
nurses we have to stand together to get
through this
awful wave one hospital's emergency
measures to cope with a shortage of
critical care staff
a 13 year old girl becomes one of
canada's youngest kobit 19 victims
emily i i said no i can't be how she
died
and the agony for her family in alberta
the impact of outbreaks at multiple oil
sands work sites
and the complaints from travelers about
a kobit testing company
global news investigates plus was anyone
watching
the oscar's dubious new distinction even
the best actor was asleep when he won
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are still engulfed in this third wave
of the pandemic but there are at least
glimmers of hope in
terms of case counts canada's seven day
average of new daily cases
fell by 2.6 percent from the week before
that means restrictions and vaccines are
slowing down the spread
but the number of people ending up in
the hospital is still on the rise up
22 percent in the last week icu cases
are up
21 percent ontario is hardest hit
877 patients are in intensive care
more than double the number from the
start of april and 24
more people died from covet 19 in
ontario
among the dead a 13 year old girl from
brampton
emily viegas died at home her father
carlos
unable to save her
was the only member of his family of
four to test negative for covet 19. his
wife
was at brampton civic on oxygen
struggling with the sickness
and when his daughter emily's condition
started to deteriorate
he didn't know what to do he did his
best to take care of her
and he thought that emily would get
better soon
we will have emily's story in a moment
but we begin with the shortage of
critical care nurses in ontario
the provincial government is now
requesting help from the canadian
military
and doctors who don't usually work in
intensive care are being redeployed as
nurses
as icu's fill up with younger patients
including pregnant women
jeff simple has our top story tonight
even for pandemic hardened hospital
staff the newest arrival to this
intensive care unit is tough to stomach
young people who get into this tragic
situation
that's even more heartbreaking a woman
in her mid-30s
and pregnant she tested positive for
covid19 and had to be intubated
doctors delivered her baby via c-section
while she was unconscious
the baby survived but the mother is now
in a coma
and we notice that she's just not
improving and in fact she's actually
getting worse
a lot to handle especially for someone
who has never done this job
before dr senzianna avranescu is an
anesthetist
who typically works in the hospital's
operating room but starting this week
she's being redeployed
as a critical care nurse i feel that
this is our chance to help this hospital
like many others is grappling with a
shortage of icu nurses
as a result every day precious icu beds
sit empty and i said if you
need my help if there's anything i can
do to coordinate and help in this
situation let me know
and this is the result or that are
continuous infusions
within days avranescu and her colleagues
organized a crash course
to train dozens of doctors to become
critical care
nurses we have to stand together it's a
camaraderie thing
it basically is supporting each other
and just kind of standing shoulder to
shoulder to
get through this this awful wave most
here are surgeons and anesthetists
who volunteered after ontario canceled
non-emergency surgeries
they're used to working in the icu and
caring for the critically ill
but the differences between jobs are
daunting
we're going to be doing things that
we're not necessarily super comfortable
doing
icu nurses are typically tasked with
caring for a single patient
they undertake years of schooling and
months of specialized training to work
in the icu
now being condensed into a couple of
days doctors normally don't manage iv
pumps or
how to turn a patient safely or how to
document as a nurse rather than a
document as a doctor they're very
different techniques
they admit the move isn't without risk
but by training up to 40 new nurses
the hospital can double its icu capacity
to ensure every patient who needs a
nurse receives one
jeff temple global news toronto
a field hospital has been set up in
toronto and it's begun taking patients
now one person was admitted to the
mobile health unit outside
sunnybrook hospital this afternoon more
patients are expected to start filling
the beds this week
it will take in people who are
recovering from covid19 to free up space
for those who are seriously ill and need
treatment
inside the hospital well
thirteen-year-old emily villegas never
made it to the hospital for treatment
she is one of the youngest people in
canada to die from covid19
she deteriorated quickly and her father
who works in a warehouse
found her in bed without vital signs
eric sorenson
has her story one of the few
consolations in the pandemic has been
the fact that few young people have died
but it can happen thirteen-year-old
emily villegas of brampton passed away
last week
seen here on her mother's social media
page emily had been sick at home and was
being cared for by her father
to our knowledge this is the first
person under the age of 19 that has died
of covet 19 within our health system in
a region with very high numbers of covet
cases
emily's father according to the globe
and mail was worried his daughter might
be taken to a hospital further away than
nearby brampton civic
where her mother was already being
treated for covet 19. this isn't
a very difficult thing to decide to do
to seek
care but what i can say is from a
reassurance standpoint if you come to
our hospital you'll get the best care we
can deliver
recently the rate of cases in ontario
has been much higher for younger age
groups particularly 20 to 29
but the rate of hospitalizations is
still higher among older ontarians and
the death rate remains highest for those
over 80.
the rate of deaths under age 20 is
exceedingly rare even with the variance
children and adolescents are much more
likely to have
no detectable disease or mild disease
than severe disease requiring
hospitalization
but families must be vigilant lisa
brown's two-year-old son
apparently got coveted at his daycare
and before long the entire family of
four was sick
the toddler took it hard for several
days he developed a cough
and a runny nose so it took him about
seven or eight days to get through the
whole
process of getting better lisa's family
recovered
but it's stressful i now invite the
honorable members to rise
for 13 year old emily villegas a moment
of silence today in the house of commons
in brampton the death of one so young is
devastating our community is
heavily um filled with its essential
workers
and in this case you know we've been
it's a warehouse worker
who their family is doing everything
right they weren't socializing they were
staying home
health professionals say marginalized
communities where essential workers are
being hit hard
there is a need for greater health care
access paid sick days
and for vaccines emily's death is a
tragic loss for the family
and for a community that has been hit so
hard by covid19
eric sorensen global news toronto
colvin cases keep rising in nova scotia
and today more restrictions were imposed
there a record 66 new infections were
reported today the highest single day
count
since the start of the pandemic starting
tomorrow halifax area schools will be
shut down to in-person learning for two
weeks
and regions outside halifax face new
restrictions including stricter limits
on indoor and outdoor gatherings
and a ban on social and sports events
we need everyone to slow down
stay close to home and take this
seriously
from yarmouth to amherst to sydney
manitoba is tightening restrictions
again as coveted infections begin to
rise again
starting on wednesday no one will be
able to have visitors at their home
indoor or outdoor for four weeks apart
from some exceptions for people who live
alone
outdoor gatherings in public places will
be capped at 10 people
manitoba's test positivity rate hit 7.6
percent today the highest
since late january when you break it
down
per capita alberta still has the most
active covid19 infections
in canada according to canada's public
health agency there are 455 cases per
100 000 people in alberta
ontario is second followed by manitoba
and bc
within alberta the hardest hit region
per capita is the municipality of wood
buffalo
home to fort mcmurray and canada's oil
sands
the region has declared a state of local
emergency it's asking for more vaccines
and fast
to help protect people from the virus
heather yurix west reports on where it's
spreading
and who is getting sick we've been sick
since last sunday
this man who we've agreed not to
identify is now isolating at a hotel
outside edmonton with covid19 he got
sick last week while working at the
canadian natural resources horizon
oil sands site near fort mcmurray a lot
of my co-workers are getting sick
um it just doesn't seem like anyone's
caring
about what's happening up there um too
many people are getting sick
and they're basically playing with
people's lives because hope it has been
known to take
people's lives cnrl would not comment on
how many of its workers are sick
but alberta health says outbreaks have
been declared at nine
oil sands work sites in the region on
sunday the regional municipality of wood
buffalo
declared a local state of emergency we
want to know what support this region
can receive
from other levels of government and one
of the most obvious i think is further
vaccine support if supply can be
provided
canada's oil sands are considered an
essential service producing
3 million barrels a day a shutdown could
lead to
fuel shortages across the continent most
of the refineries
in that whole region are dependent on
production from the oil sands
so it would have a big implication if
the oil sands
had to ramp back production and you know
if it went way down it would be
devastating of course 19 doesn't care
and in alberta the more highly
transmissible variants
are fueling exponential growth they can
be up to two and a half times more
infectious than the strain we were
dealing with last year
but we also have to remember that
although our provincial numbers are now
almost as high as they were at the peak
in december we still have fewer
restrictions in place
meaning the virus will continue to
spread among essential workers at the
sites of alberta's oil sands
and the community just beyond heather
urex west global news
calgary the b-117 variant first detected
in the uk has now been found in canada's
far
north nonavoid's chief public health
officer says testing has confirmed the
variant is circulating in the capital
iqaluit
the territory has 47 active cases now
most are in
iqaluit officials are urging people who
have not been vaccinated
to get their shots canada is making slow
and steady progress
in getting people vaccinated 29 percent
of the population has received at least
one dose now
almost 3 percent has received both doses
the government is expecting a big boost
in deliveries this week nearly 2 million
more doses
as abigail beeman explains the ramp up
can't happen soon enough
this line to nab a jab for only about a
hundred available at this ottawa walk-in
clinic
my husband's on the 15 or 17 waiting
lists so it's very very difficult to be
able to find something
i'm on about 17 waiting lists called all
the pharmacies in the city and the only
reason why i'm sitting here is because
my son hooked me up with vaccine hunters
many ontarians frustrated they have to
rely on a volunteer-run twitter account
to get the shot
they may be the lucky ones some ontario
pharmacies have been cancelling
appointments they will all run out of
astrazeneca within the week
hoping today's reports the u.s will
share at 60 million
doses with the world could help we're
hopeful with the federal government's
discussions
in the u.s of bringing up astrazeneca
that that will happen but right now we
have
no certainty so it's likely there will
be an interruption of supply
pharmacists are in talks with the
province to launch a pilot program to
administer pfizer as soon as this week
it's offered the steadiest supply with
another million shots coming this week
and 2 million a week for all of may and
for the first time
the one shot johnson and johnson vaccine
will arrive at the end of this week
300 thousand will roll out to the
provinces next week
the vaccine residency is actually a very
broad and complex
issue jnj has a similar pr battle as
astrazeneca with rare blood clots
causing a pause in the u.s
lifted as of friday these vaccines are
highly effective
nearly 100 percent effective at
preventing those really severe outcomes
and the safety concerns that have come
up
are around risks that are very very rare
the national advisory committee on
immunization has not yet issued guidance
on the use of johnson and johnson saying
friday it was waiting to see what
happened in the u.s
and so far no provinces have taken up
nasty's recommendations on astrazeneca
allowing it to be given to people in
their 30s
abigail beeman global news ottawa
begging for life-saving oxygen coming up
india's desperate pleas
for help
[Music]
oxygen is in such short supply in india
families who can afford to
are paying black market prices to get
canisters so their loved ones can
breathe
about 1.7 million people have tested
positive in the last five days
that is half a million more than
canada's total case count
more than 352 000 new cases were
reported in the last day a world record
and 2 800 deaths were confirmed although
as redmond shannon reports it's believed
india's actual death toll
is much higher
roadside oxygen on the streets of delhi
set up by volunteers at a sikh temple
among the patients who were turned away
from overflowing hospitals
is 32 year old abu sadat
his brother tries to keep him lucid we
don't know
if he survived his father and volunteers
decry the government's handling of the
brutal
deadly surge in covert 19 cases i don't
know what government is doing
but then we can do it why can't
government not doing
prime minister narendra modi has ordered
twitter to remove
posts that criticize the government's
handling of the pandemic critics say
modi didn't take the threat of a second
wave
seriously and is now too slow to react
so serious is the situation officials
are even advising people to wear masks
in their own houses
amid growing concerns about the b1617
variant definitely there is more deaths
than the recorded ones this is for sure
dr
harjit singh bhatti says patients are on
average
younger and sicker than during india's
first wave
even the vaccinated are getting infected
although
they may not be as ill university
professors
army officers when such influential
people are not able to get the beds then
you can just think about the poor people
how much suffering they are facing right
now
the uk the eu and the who are sending
aid
including machines to produce oxygen we
absolutely
need to help other countries around the
world and right now india is going
through a horrible situation the
canadian government says it has been in
touch with india about sending ppe
and ventilators but as canada struggles
with a pandemic at home
no details of aid have been confirmed as
yet
redmond shannon global news london
ahead the toronto startup facing
complaints about its covet testing at
canada's borders
hundreds of thousands of international
travelers are still making their way
into canada each month
and making sure they are properly tested
for covet 19 is critical
switch health is a toronto area startup
doing that testing
but many travelers say the company is
struggling to keep up with demand
as roberta bell reports there are fears
it could leave canada open
to more deadly variants yeah there's a
little video of you
that says nurse will be with you shortly
tyler harvey in calgary says that wasn't
the case for him
he went online to do a supervised covet
test on march
9 after returning from a work trip to
the u.s
it showed of 1418 people
i realized that i might not actually be
getting the test done
on day 10. he says he waited for five
hours only to be cut off when the
platform closed
the next day he says he got disconnected
again
i called public health canada
a couple times and asked i said hey like
i know i'm not supposed to leave
quarantine until i get this day 10 test
so what am i supposed to do here
toronto-based startups which health won
a federal contract in february
and now manages coronavirus tests for
hundreds of thousands of travelers
arriving in canada
the nurse will take you through the
following steps travelers swab
themselves in their homes or hotel rooms
while in rn watches via video chat
then couriers deliver the samples to
labs
but global news found hundreds of
negative online reviews
from allegations of incomplete test kits
to login issues
long lines and problems with pickup we
spoke to about a dozen people who
complained about the system
it's clear that switch is a giant mess
greg skinner was back in bc after
visiting his ten-year-old daughter who
lives in the states
he says he spoke to a customer service
agent on the phone on march 10 to
complain
and said he couldn't get through to a
nurse and also in that process then he
told me
let's do it yourself too while the
public health agency of canada says it's
not aware of cases like this one
it is aware a small number of travelers
were unable to book their telehealth
appointments within the testing time
frame
and is working with other federal
partners and the company on solutions
switch health says it can't respond to
individual user allegations
but that it has advised its call
representatives all
tests must be nurse monitored and as a
still new company
it says it needs time to adjust to the
exponential demand
it's adding and training more staff
switch health told global news that 250
online complaints represented only .007
percent
of all the tests administered to date
but with new more contagious and more
deadly variants continuing to arrive
public health experts say the situation
could get worse
roberta bell global news regina
next an historic win and a big upset at
the oscars
movies have given us much needed
distraction even if we have to watch
them on small screens
but our love for awards shows has dimmed
considerably
according to the nielsen ratings
hollywood's biggest night the academy
awards
was watched by fewer than 10 million
people last night
a record low and a 58 drop from last
year
and the oscar goes to
nomad land nomad land won three of the
biggest prizes including
best picture and chloe zhao who was born
in china
made history becoming the first asian
woman to win
best director this is for anyone
who has the faith and the courage to
hold on to the goodness in themselves
the chinese government imposed virtual
news blackout and censored social media
posts about her win
the final award was best actor the late
chadwick boseman was nominated for ma
rainey's black bottom
and it was thought he might win and the
academy award
for actor goes to anthony hopkins
the father but it was anthony hopkins
who got the oscar for his role in the
father
except he was at home in wales asleep
he sent in an acceptance speech this
morning
very grateful to the academy and thank
you
and i want to pay tribute to chadwick
boseman
who's taken from us far too early
it is hopkins second oscar and at age 83
he is the oldest actor to receive one
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the town of
ituna saskatchewan northeast of regina
please email your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you